bonjour à tous on parle beaucoup d'apple
parce qu'il ya effectivement une
actualité toujours une volant du côté de
chez apple c'est quand même le leader le
numéro un avec samsung au niveau des
smartphones de la téléphonie mobile
apple a mis un coup de pied un peu dans
sa propre fourmilière à l'année dernière
en sortant l'iphone bis on voit que ça
change pas mal de choses et surtout on
se pose la question du changement de
dénomination parce que oui on va pas
appeler les khroubis l'iphone 11 iphone
12 d'iphone traite en plus que l'iphone
dit s'écrit avec une grande croix donc
un moment qu'est ce qui va se passer
et justement on a des infos hyper chaude
pour savoir ce qui va se passer comment
devrait s'appeler nouveau iphone à
partir de 2018 et ça on en parle
[Musique]
dès qu'on parle d'apple forcément je
sais ça suscite les passions il ya ceux
qui adorent la mare qui fondamentalement
comme diraient certains d'entre vous
sont des fanboy à un son d effet apple
il ya ceux qui n'aiment pas du tout a
contrario puis il ya les autres
tu trouve ça bien pas bien tu sens fitch
et ils s'en foutent complètement
et puis il ya un mois au milieu qui vous
parle d'apple parce que je trouve que
c'est une marque qui a eu je dirais une
vraie un vrai intérêt à innover à
innover à démocratiser pas mal de choses
à essayer et à toujours être je dirais
fer de lance dans pas mal de domaines
alors moi j'ai aujourd'hui un produit de
chez apple j'ai un iphone 6 s il ya
quelques années mais qui fait encore la
faire pour l'instant je ne touche du
bois je n'aurais pas touche ma tête ça
c'est déjà pas mal
donc on voit que apple change pas mal de
choses
l'iphone 10 il était plutôt pas mal on
va pas se mentir il est plutôt pas mal
le point négatif qu'on a eue avec
l'iphone dit c'est qu'ils ont pris un
peu le meilleur de ce qui se faisait
ils ont tous dans un smartphone en
disant voilà le smartphone du futur pas
réellement le smartphone du futur en
tout cas c'était le smartphone du futur
la vision des produits du futur d'apple
du point de vue du smartphone c'est vrai
c'était leur vision du futur mais c'est
pas le truc le plus dingue haut et plus
innovants du monde alors après
effectivement il ya des choses super
bien fait le produit est extrêmement
bien fait
la petite encoche a priori sont pas
plantés parce que tout le monde se
positionne dessus donc tout le monde
mais de l'encoche à droite à gauche
naples un an de plus en plus sous
android
why not la recharge par induction
existait déjà il y avait pas mal de
choses ont failli saïdi c'est un truc
était vraiment plutôt bien fait ça pour
le coup on va pas se mentir
donc c'est vraiment un produit très très
fort du point de vue de chez apple en
tout cas cet iphone d sauf qu'on voit
très bien que en arrive à un moment
l'iphone 7,7 +88 plus l'iphone 10 pour
les 10 ans pas d'iphone 9
il y aurait aucun intérêt à sortir un
iphone 9 d'un point de vue marketing via
prévoit sortir d'iphone dit ce sera un
mythe complet et attaquer directement
après qu'un iphone aux on va cogner plus
alors la question s'est posée avant de
se dire comment vont saper ses iphone
j'ai pensé longtemps ça peut encore être
le cas mais là encore son de la rumeur
on n'est pas sûr de l'info vraiment
vraiment précis j'ai pensé longtemps qui
pourrait appeler les iphone panthères
léopard snow leopard avoir un peu comme
on retrouve ce qu'on retrouve au niveau
de la dénomination de mac os à voir en
tout cas l'analyste robert tsira une
info qui était relayé un par
appleinsider pense que le nom sera tout
autre parce que ce qui est sûr c'est que
ce jour il a changé
une façon de nous d'ailleurs dit moi en
commentaire ce que vous en pensez
comment vont s'appeler pour vous c'est
plutôt un iphone donc c'est très clair
que ces iphone vont changer de nom et
lui il pense que très clairement apple
va faire dans la sobriété comme ils
savent très bien le faire au lieu de
l'appeler les faux bond il faut ni 12
les phonons ce plus l'iphone ans + gamma
je ne sais quoi mettre une bonne heure
avant fou non ils vont l'appeler pour le
produit d'entrée de gamme le produit de
base comme yavé l'iphone 6 57 ils
appelleront juste iphone juste l'iphone
comme qu'on peut retrouver un peu sur
l'ipad
tous les ans vous à vannes ipad qui sort
on y passe et l'ipad c'est qu'il a
commise n'est pas neuf non c'est l'ipad
donc là on devrait avoir juste l'iphone
pour le produit plus haut de gamme
on devrait avoir un iphone x un iphone
bis je pense qu'ils ont tout continue à
l'appeler l'iphone 10 et pour le produit
haut de gamme avec un grand écran on
devrait avoir pour le coup l'iphone
disent plus donc tout ça se tient c'est
assez logique
et en plus de ça cette année on devrait
avoir en plus une nouvelle version de
l'iphone special edition
l'iphone est ce l'iphone et ce dès lors
on se refaire un petit point n'a pas dû
chronologique devrait être annoncée au
tabloïd avait lui d'ici au mois de juin
2018 la très très proches
le nouveau iphone et ce2 sask en tout
cas super cool emparé d'un petit
smartphone 1 2 4 pouces on garderait le
design actuel du design codes et des
smartphones de calais phone est deux on
devrait avoir la puissance d'un iphone
cette fin tout ça j'en ai déjà parlé
dans une précédente vidéo on va en
reparler abonnez vous parce que vous
allez voir que cet iphone s 2 s'il
arrive et je suis sûr qu'il va arriver
il devrait garder un peu cette base pour
les personnes qui aiment ce petit format
très intéressant et justement alors
maintenant on se recentrer sur l'iphone
l'iphone dit c'est l'iphone 10 plus
l'iphone tout simplement devrait avoir
un écran 6,1 pouces du lcd contrat
trouvait au mois de septembre l'iphone
dit ce sera un écran 5 8 pouces oled
alors que l'iphone 10 plus ce serait un
écran circulent
5 pouces oled un très grand écran et
d'ailleurs on board pas ici très très
très peu de temps de cet iphone 10 plus
parce qu'il devrait y avoir un nouveau
truc qu'on n'a pas vu chez apple depuis
des années arrive et sur un smartphone
ne mène jamais vu arriver chez apple
vous allez voir c'est un truc de dingue
donc rester connecté abonnez vous donc
on voit très bien que apple veut va
retravailler sa gamme la travailler la
retravaille en termes de design
maintenant valve a retravaillé en terme
d'image en termes de nom pour quelque
chose de toujours plus sobre sait déjà
ce qu'il faut comme je vous disais sur
l'ipad l'ipad pro vous avez déclinaison
ipad pro fonction des écrans ce qu'on a
aussi sur les macbook macbook pro
macbook air on n'a pas le macbook pro
2010 est même bon premier avec des
numéros macbook pro 12 dont nous
produisons l'a pas on a juste un marque
un nom une identité forte et c'est la
même chose qu'on sera trouvée sur les
ait fana dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
théorie est vous la trouvez assez
pertinente est ce que vous pensez qu'a
contrario apple va garder la
numérotation actuelle est ce qu'ils vont
coller des petits noms des petits dont
2,2 de petits animaux comme le jaguar
panther snow leopard est compagnie tiger
et que ça j'ai encore au nom de l'
iphone mark et moi tout ça j'ai hâte de
voir ce que vous en pensez comme
d'habitude vous invite à me laisser des
jolies pousse à vous abonner à marquer
toutes vos questions suggestions
directement en bas en dessous juste là
dans les commentaires
n'oubliez pas de rester connecté vous
êtes les meilleurs soyez sages prenez
soin de vous et on se revoit très très
très bientôt
parce qu'on a plein d'infos
croustillantes qui arrive donc soyez
sages à meadow
[Musique]